[Music]
I'm just gonna tell you a little bit
about my mom I'm going to tell you about
my mom I was raised by my mom and Maya
we eat that so I like to say I was
raised in a space matriarchal magic my
dad he just he wasn't around so my mom
really had to you know pick up the slack
it was just the two of us up until I
left for college and that was our family
unit my mom was left with four kids a
fifteen-year-old a fourteen-year-old an
eight year old and a three year old I
was raised by two very powerful for a
tireless women tireless mothers for that
matter both of whom have not only taught
me about patience but about the myriad
of ways in which family can manifest my
mom was mom and dad for me for so much
of my life and I'm just really grateful
for it she didn't have a degree she
didn't have a job of any kind when she
moved out there she we just was forced
to figure it out she was able to get us
out of a very unhealthy marriage she did
it all on her own
just now as an adult I'm starting to
realize how strong my mom is she would
work but she also went to school on the
weekend - and then she worked full-time
during the week she works six days out
of the week just to provide for me and
my sister she never complains she has
the best sense of humor that she started
in house cleaning business
that since its conception has allowed
her to provide me with everything that
I've needed to have a good start to my
life Greta I never knew that anything
was wrong I always had everything I
wanted any toy any game system all of it
my mom just got me stuff I mean my mom
was the Easter Bunny the tooth fairy or
Santa everything we never wanted for
anything in the world and then the older
I got the more I realized she sacrificed
so much she was there every single
sporting outing every single choir
concert no matter how far it was she was
there and she was cheering me on
my mom took it upon herself to teach me
how to drive and she said mija if you
want to drive you got to learn how to
change a tire how to check all y'all how
to do all that stuff and I said mom I
was like what are you gonna teach me
about doing that you're a girl and she's
like sweetie
got it all wrong this lady walked up the
house pop the hood to her truck if this
lady just starts going at it after my
dad passed my mom would put us all to
bed and wit her room and cry herself to
sleep when I was growing up I didn't
always appreciate a little own fully
comprehend the real impact of the burden
that she had to carry his primary
provider of our household shoutout to
all the single moms who are pushing
forward and just doing everything they
can to provide for their kids I really
really wish I had understood how much my
mom was doing at a younger age so I
could have helped her a little bit more
she is the biggest believer in me in
this entire world more so than myself
she doesn't ever fail to tell me that
she loves me she was always proud of me
very proud I don't know why he was
always proud of me didn't matter for
what I don't know I don't think single
moms get enough credit because it takes
a lot to be both mommy
you really do give up a lot of yourself
when you're raising people mom I will
eat that I'm so gratefully indebted to
the both of you thank you for all of the
love for the support I guess all that
remains to be said is thank you mom I
love you a lot
capacity I asked my MA damn
[Music]